si vous pouviez aller n'importe où dans le
monde entier, où iriez-vous J'ai toujours
voulu faire partie de quelque chose de plus grand oui
Avalon parle d'un groupe de personnes qui
se retrouvent au début d'Hollywood à une
époque d'extrême dépravation, de débauche
et d'excès
c'est la plus grande chose  J'ai déjà essayé
de faire de l'
action c'était une époque tellement folle c'était juste
sauvage comme le Far West
l'histoire suit plusieurs personnages
ils ont l'ambition de faire partie de
quelque chose de plus grand qu'eux nous
devons innover nous avons  pour inspirer
Jack Conrad est le plus grand acteur de cinéma
au sommet de son jeu et il appelle
beaucoup de plans prenez deux images de la
queue et trois autres devant Manny est
notre guide à travers l'histoire
ce sont les yeux et les oreilles d'un
point de vue extérieur  de vue c'est un rêveur
quelqu'un qui essaie de trouver son chemin
vous pouvez le sentir c'est plus grand que la
vie
Nelly est une actrice en herbe elle est comme
une tornade
et elle ne laissera personne se mettre en
travers de son chemin je suis arrivé ici à mes conditions  pas le
leur,
c'est une expérience cinématographique unique et différente
et ça va être vraiment
incroyable
ça montre un côté d'Hollywood au-delà de ce que
vous auriez pu imaginer,
je veux dire tellement de problèmes que les
gens vont être vraiment choqués de
voir à quel point c'était fou est-ce que ça va être
quoi  ça va être
c'est vraiment drôle parfois regarde ces
idiots
c'est vraiment sexy parfois le film est si
gros c'est vraiment une épopée
c'est juste phénoménal
hé mon grand
[Musique]